We're now continue
with some announcement
relevant to our celebration.
Last week, the students in a
2016 Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
IEP design seminar
assembled their installation
in Memorial Lobby.
We invite you to view
the exhibit from now
until the end of the day
tomorrow in Memorial Lobby.
The 2016 all MIT
Diversity Forum is
scheduled for Friday,
April 29, from 8:30 a.m.
To 5:30 p.m.
The theme this year is
reflect, understand, act.
The keynote speaker will
be Jelani Cobb, Director
of Africana Studies at the
University of Connecticut.
Please save the date,
and we hope to see you
all at this wonderful event.
We'll conclude today's program
with the singing of the Lift
Every Voice and Sing.
We ask that you join in and sing
the first verse of the song.
The lyrics are located on
the back of your program.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SINGING]